This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences essential
这是一档 IHeart 播客。保证真实。您是否有意愿去做出真正的改变？LaCite 学院为您提供“依赖与心理健康”课程。获取核心能力，
for accompany and support the people confronted to the difficulties of health and of dependence. Construise a career enrichisance
以陪伴和支持那些面临健康和依赖困难的人们。构建一份充实的职业生涯，
to service of the community francophone of all the country. Donnay of Coney. It's possible
服务于全国的法语社区。给予关怀。这在 CIT 是可能的。
with the CIT. Visit CollageLacacac .C. D.M. A new initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Health, supported by Santee Canada.
请访问 CollageLacacac.C.D.M。这是国家健康培训联盟的一项新倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveith and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum.
那些眼睛里空洞无物。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。Evil，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹 Creveith 和 DePippo 谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo 在被判处最高刑罚后，没有表现出任何悔意，显得泰然自若。
I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chat. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
我说我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Bone Valley 频道中的 The Devil's Quarry。快乐至关重要，但也难以捉摸，但现在有一种令人兴奋的新方法可以开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程。Joy 101。这是一档由我 Hoda Kotby 主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的节目。打开您免费的 IHeart Radio 应用程序。搜索 Joy 101 并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier El Chichariot Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Here. Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
由 CVS 呈现的 Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbi。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是 Javier El Chichariot Hernandez，请在 IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Learning to Be Human。
For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weed-In-House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created this show why I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares Un-House stories and news from the Un-House perspective. Listen to Wey and Howls on the I-Hard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Speck, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode.
多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个单一的群体。Weed-In-House 是一档正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是 Theo Henderson，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创办了这个节目。我们已经成长为两届威比奖得主的播客，也是唯一一个从无家可归者视角分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。请在 I-Hard Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Wey and Howls。大家好。我是 Jemma Speck，欢迎回到《你的 20 岁心理学》，这是一档我们探讨 20 岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。
as we break down the psychology of our 20s before we get into it. I know I said this in the last episode, but I want to keep reminding you all that this episode of the podcast and many others are now on Netflix in the UK, Australia, Canada, US, Germany, Malaysia, South Africa. I don't know. There's a lot of them, just to name a few. So if you are a fan of watching podcasts, watching this podcast, as you listen to it, this is your chance you can go and watch the video version of this very,
当我们剖析 20 岁的心理时，在开始之前。我知道我在上一集说过，但我还是要提醒大家，这一集播客和许多其他节目现在已经在英国、澳大利亚、加拿大、美国、德国、马来西亚、南非的 Netflix 上线了。我不知道，还有很多，仅举几例。所以，如果你喜欢观看播客，在收听时观看这个播客，这是你的机会，你可以去观看这个视频版本，
episode right now. Just go and search the psychology of your 20s on your Netflix app. Give it a go. See what all the fuss is about. See what I can't shut up about. And I hope you enjoy it. Today, we are talking about how to get out of a funk, how to get out of a season of life that honestly just feels very bland. And more than just bland, feels very boring, frustrating, maybe even slightly depressing. I think it is so totally normal to go through periods like this, to go through periods where things are just not on the vibrational length that you want them to be, but what can be worrying is when it begins to tank our entire perception of life and we think that we're never going to get out of this state of mind. And it changes what we think we're capable of. It changes
就在这一集。只需在您的 Netflix 应用程序上搜索《你的 20 岁心理学》。试一试。看看大家都在讨论什么。看看我为什么喋喋不休。希望你喜欢它。今天，我们讨论的是如何摆脱低谷，如何摆脱那种老实说感觉非常平淡的生活阶段。而且不仅仅是平淡，感觉非常无聊、令人沮丧，甚至可能有点抑郁。我认为经历这样的时期是非常正常的，经历那些事情不在你想要的振动频率上的时期，但令人担忧的是，当它开始摧毁我们对生活的整体感知，并且我们认为自己永远无法摆脱这种心态时。它改变了我们对自己能力的看法。它改变了
what we think the world is capable of. I found myself in a funk these past few months. I was just angry. I was just really angry at how much is required to simply be an adult and I was angry at the world and I was angry at everybody around me. And it really sucked, but luckily I've been kind of clawing my way out of that and whether it's because it's suddenly summer in the UK spring, but the sun is peaking through or whether it is the fact that I've been having some hard but very kind chats with myself. I have been feeling like this is paid off and I'm out of this like little chapter I was in for a while. So I wanted to kind of share what I did, share why we end up in these kind of low points. And yeah, of course, some tips, some tips that you could put into
我们对世界能力的看法。过去几个月我发现自己陷入了低谷。我只是很生气。我真的对仅仅作为一个成年人所需要付出的努力感到非常生气，我对世界感到生气，我对周围的每个人都感到生气。这真的很糟糕，但幸运的是，我一直在努力摆脱那种状态，无论是英国突然进入了夏天，春天来了，阳光透过云层，还是因为我一直在与自己进行一些艰难但非常友善的交谈。我一直觉得这得到了回报，我已经走出了我经历了一段时间的这个小篇章。所以我想要分享我做了什么，分享我们为什么会陷入这些低谷。当然，还有一些小贴士，一些你可以
place literally after you listen to this episode to get yourself out of a funk. So without further ado, let's get into it. So what do we mean by being in a funk, right? I think we all know what it feels like to be in a bad mood. There's a very normal part of being human and of experiencing kind of like the ups and downs of life. We all know the experience of waking up and just feeling like the world is against us. But sometimes that feeling, that terrible mood lingers. And it's not just one morning. It's every morning. It's every evening. And it's every lunchtime. And it just becomes so all-encompassing. I think the biggest sign you are in a funk right now is when you find yourself taking every single neutral situation and unconsciously without choosing to turning them into negatives, right?
在听完这一集后立即付诸实践，让自己摆脱低谷。那么，废话不多说，让我们开始吧。那么，陷入低谷是什么意思呢？我想我们都知道心情不好的感觉。这是作为人类、体验生活起起落落的非常正常的一部分。我们都知道醒来时感觉世界与我们作对的经历。但有时那种感觉，那种糟糕的心情会挥之不去。不仅仅是一个早晨。是每一个早晨。是每一个晚上。是每一个午餐时间。它变得如此无处不在。我认为你现在陷入低谷的最大迹象是，当你发现自己将每一个中立的情况，在没有选择的情况下，下意识地将它们变成了负面情况，对吧？
Everything that happens to you ends up being terrible. Everything that happens to you, you interpret to be negative. It might feel like you just can't catch a break, whether it's to do with work, love, money, friendships, all of the above, or even just like daily existence. everything is annoying, everything is slow, everything goes wrong. In addition, I think what compounds this is that it can be really unclear as to why we're feeling this way. And I think feeling stuck and helpless are often signs of being in a funk as well, knowing you are the bad mood and not being able to change it. You might be thinking, Gemma, that sounds very similar to being depressed.
发生在你身上的一切最终都变得很糟糕。发生在你身上的一切，你都将其解读为负面的。这可能感觉就像你无法喘息，无论是工作、爱情、金钱、友谊，还是以上所有，甚至只是日常生活。一切都很烦人，一切都很慢，一切都出了问题。此外，我认为加剧这一点的是，我们为什么会有这种感觉可能非常不清楚。我认为感到被困和无助通常也是陷入低谷的迹象，知道自己心情不好却无法改变它。你可能会想，Gemma，这听起来和抑郁症很像。
And yeah, I get why you would think that honestly. And we can't deny they definitely go hand in hand a lot of the time. And often the funk is the precursor. But being in a funk is not clinical and it's temporary. Depression is chronic often and it's all encompassing. And it involves chemical, biological and social and environmental triggers. What really differentiates a funk from a depressive state is that underneath it all, your capacity for pleasure is still intact. a good conversation with like somebody that you love or like a really beautiful sunny day or like a really great meal, these things still register on your radar when you are in a funk. In contrast with depression, situations that would normally bring you joy.
是的，我明白你为什么会这么想，老实说。我们不能否认它们在很多时候确实是相辅相成的。通常低谷是抑郁的前兆。但陷入低谷不是临床上的，而且是暂时的。抑郁症通常是慢性的，而且是全面的。它涉及化学、生物、社会和环境触发因素。真正区分低谷和抑郁状态的是，在这一切之下，你享受快乐的能力仍然完好无损。与你爱的人进行一次愉快的交谈，或者一个非常美丽的晴天，或者一顿非常棒的饭菜，当你陷入低谷时，这些事情仍然会出现在你的雷达上。相比之下，在抑郁症中，那些通常会给你带来快乐的情况。
You know, you could literally land your dream job. You could be on holiday. You could be spending quality time with your family. Even those moments cannot lift the black cloud that is present. So it's important to know the difference because if it is a difference, because if it is a depressed state you are dealing with, obviously most, if not all of the stuff we're talking about today probably isn't going to register and isn't going to help in the same way if you are just in a thunk. And I think it's rather dismissive to conflate the two. Both suck a lot,
你知道，你可能会得到你梦寐以求的工作。你可能正在度假。你可能正在与家人共度美好时光。即使是那些时刻也无法驱散那朵笼罩着的乌云。所以了解区别很重要，因为如果这是你正在处理的抑郁状态，显然我们今天讨论的大部分内容，如果不是全部，可能都不会引起共鸣，也不会像你只是陷入低谷那样有帮助。我认为将两者混为一谈是相当轻视的。两者都很糟糕，
but depression needs more of a clinical intervention, just so we are very clear on that before we get into kind of the origins of being in the state of mind. So back to the funk. What creates this? You would probably know this. It's not just one thing. It's often the cumulative load of what we call major and minor stresses. Work sucks. That's the first thing. And then you're not getting enough sleep. And then you're really struggling to make new friends. And then you're really kind of tired with your old friends. And then you really can't find the time to go to the gym. And then, you know, all these things on one and top of the other, you're not making as much money and you're feeling detached from your hobbies. One thing on its own would probably be fine, but with multiple things, essentially you don't know what to focus on first.
但抑郁症需要更多的临床干预，在我们进入这种心态的起源之前，我们要非常清楚这一点。回到低谷。是什么造成了这种情况？你可能知道。不仅仅是一件事。它通常是我们所说的主要和次要压力的累积负荷。工作很糟糕。这是第一件事。然后你睡眠不足。然后你真的很难结交新朋友。然后你对老朋友感到非常厌倦。然后你真的找不到时间去健身房。然后，你知道，所有这些事情叠加在一起，你赚的钱不多，你对自己的爱好感到疏离。单单一件事可能没问题，但多件事叠加在一起，本质上你不知道先关注什么。
And secondly, it's just the weight of it all just gets a lot heavier, naturally. Here is something we talk about a lot in psychology. When stresses aren't acute, but instead small, ongoing and unresolved, your brain doesn't get the same signal that the threat has passed. Instead, your threat detection system, your anxious thoughts, whatever it is, stay mildly activated over long periods of time. This means cortisol and other stress hormones are not being released in sharp bursts that then peak and plateau and decline, but in a sustained lower level way constantly. Over time, this means that your allostatic load, which is essentially the wear and tear on your
其次，这一切的重量自然变得更重了。这是我们在心理学中经常讨论的事情。当压力不是急性的，而是小的、持续的和未解决的时，你的大脑不会收到威胁已经过去的相同信号。相反，你的威胁检测系统，你的焦虑想法，无论是什么，都会在很长一段时间内保持轻微的激活状态。这意味着皮质醇和其他压力荷尔蒙不是以尖锐的爆发方式释放，然后达到峰值、平稳并下降，而是以一种持续的、较低水平的方式不断释放。随着时间的推移，这意味着你的异位负荷，本质上是你的
body and brain from adjusting to repeated stress, it just gets higher and higher. Your system is constantly trying to maintain balance and recover, but if you can't keep up, that comes at a cost. the fatigue you feel, the reduced executive functioning, which also means that you then find it harder to think of a solution, that is the cost of all of this. And often the only natural response is for your brain, your mind, your body to go, let's just shut it all down, let's numb ourselves out, let's blunt all the senses so that we can get through this. So that's the first contributing factor to being in a funk combined cumulative stresses. The second is actually something quite simple, which is a lack of novelty. Novelty and having new experiences, I feel like we talk about this a lot, but seeing new things,
身体和大脑因适应反复压力而产生的磨损，只会越来越高。你的系统一直在努力保持平衡和恢复，但如果你跟不上，那是有代价的。你感到的疲劳，执行功能的降低，这也意味着你随后发现更难想出解决方案，这就是这一切的代价。通常唯一的自然反应是你的大脑、你的思想、你的身体说，让我们把这一切都关掉，让我们麻木自己，让我们钝化所有的感官，这样我们才能度过难关。所以这是陷入低谷的第一个促成因素，累积的压力。第二个其实很简单，就是缺乏新鲜感。新鲜感和拥有新的体验，我觉得我们经常谈论这个，但看到新的事物，
having small shifts in routine, being excited about something, that's not just a luxury that has been proven and shown to be psychologically both necessary and protective. You need to have new experiences if you want to feel like yourself. In fact, there was a 2019 study, I think it was done in California, that found that novelty is not only enjoyable, duh, it actually sparks the brain to explore more, meaning we find more novelty, meaning we find more things that we find fun,
在日常生活中进行小的改变，对某事感到兴奋，这不仅仅是一种奢侈，它已被证明在心理上既是必要的也是具有保护性的。如果你想感觉像你自己，你需要有新的体验。事实上，2019 年的一项研究，我想是在加利福尼亚完成的，发现新鲜感不仅令人愉快，废话，它实际上激发了大脑去探索更多，这意味着我们发现了更多的新鲜感，这意味着我们发现了更多我们觉得有趣的事情，
more good things, and also more solutions, because it switches on a curiosity, exploratory mindset. When everything is the same as it's always been, or has been for a while, you know, our brain is kind of like a zoo animal or like an animal in captivity. It like becomes accustomed to things simply being the way they are. And it's kind of like gnawing at the bars, being like, let me out. So boredom is a big factor here. Interestingly, but not surprisingly, boredom doesn't get a research spotlight. It has been researched far less than
更多的好事，以及更多的解决方案，因为它开启了一种好奇、探索的心态。当一切都和以前一样，或者已经有一段时间了，你知道，我们的大脑就像动物园里的动物或圈养的动物。它变得习惯于事情就是这样。它有点像在啃咬栅栏，好像在说，放我出去。所以无聊是这里的一个大因素。有趣的是，但并不令人惊讶的是，无聊并没有得到研究的关注。它被研究的程度远低于
other emotions like happiness or sadness or like the big flashy ones. because I think scientifically people think of boredom is quite trivial, but it's such an unexplored emotion, and it sits so closely to other more headline-grabbing emotions like loneliness and sadness when it comes to our emotional well-being. Here's the thing, boredom, when practiced, when welcomed, can do wonderful things for your imagination, wonderful things for your creativity,
其他情绪，如快乐或悲伤，或者那些大的、引人注目的情绪。因为我认为在科学上，人们认为无聊是相当琐碎的，但它是一种未被探索的情绪，当涉及到我们的情绪健康时，它与孤独和悲伤等其他更引人注目的情绪非常接近。事情是这样的，无聊，当被实践、被欢迎时，可以为你的想象力做美妙的事情，为你的创造力做美妙的事情，
because your brain basically has to entertain itself. and be imaginative. But when boredom is involuntary, persistent, chronic, it literally shrinks our perspective of the world and makes it narrower. For example, a study from 2015 on like, it was like 800 students found that students who scored high on a boredom scale also tended to score very high on a depression scale. scale. Bordom is a psychological feature of depressed states, which we know are linked to being
因为你的大脑基本上必须自娱自乐。并且富有想象力。但当无聊是无意识的、持续的、慢性的时，它确实缩小了我们对世界的看法，使它变得更狭窄。例如，2015 年对大约 800 名学生进行的一项研究发现，在无聊量表上得分高的学生也倾向于在抑郁量表上得分非常高。无聊是抑郁状态的一个心理特征，我们知道这与处于
in this funk light state as well. It can also make us more impulsive, can drive us more towards harmful behaviours. A very famous study from the University of Virginia in 2014, recruited like hundreds of undergrads, hundreds of community members, and they got them to take part in these like what they called prolonged thinking periods. Participants were placed in these like empty rooms on like a chair with a desk in front of them and they were asked, they weren't allowed to bring in any of their belongings, no books, no nothing, no pens, no phones. And they were asked to sit there and think. And during that time, they were given the option to give themselves an electric shock if they wanted to or to just sit quietly.
这种低谷状态也是相关的。它还可以使我们更冲动，可以驱使我们走向更有害的行为。2014 年弗吉尼亚大学的一项非常著名的研究，招募了数百名本科生，数百名社区成员，让他们参与这些他们称之为“长时间思考期”的活动。参与者被安置在这些空房间里，坐在桌子前的椅子上，他们被要求，不允许带入任何属于他们的物品，没有书，什么都没有，没有笔，没有手机。他们被要求坐在那里思考。在那段时间里，他们可以选择如果愿意的话给自己电击，或者只是安静地坐着。
The results were drastic. Even though all participants had previously stated, they would not even accept money to be shocked and they would pay money to avoid being shocked. When they were in this situation of boredom, 67% of men, 25% of women, chose to continue to inflict themselves with this electric shock rather than sit there and think quietly and be boredom.
结果是剧烈的。尽管所有参与者之前都表示，他们甚至不会接受金钱去被电击，而且他们会付钱来避免被电击。当他们处于这种无聊的情况下时，67% 的男性，25% 的女性，选择继续对自己进行这种电击，而不是坐在那里安静地思考和无聊。
bored. Sometimes, like, that's a great example of how much we try and avoid boredom. And sometimes the things we do when we're bored might not be actively harmful like an electric shock, but they're not great either. You know, they, it drives us to just continue spiraling into the state of doing behaviors and performing behaviors that, like, aren't helpful. And so when we are in a funk and kind of questioning, like, why am I doing all these things that, like, actually aren't helping me, but I can't stop. Why am I drinking all the time? Like, why am I not reading before bed? Why am I like continuing to not make moves that I want to make? That boredom that you are experiencing all the time is actually shutting down your brain's ability to make creative,
无聊。有时，这是一个很好的例子，说明我们多么努力地避免无聊。有时我们在无聊时所做的事情可能不像电击那样具有主动伤害性，但它们也不太好。你知道，它们驱使我们继续陷入做行为和表现出行为的螺旋，这些行为并不有帮助。所以当我们陷入低谷并质疑，比如，为什么我一直在做所有这些实际上并没有帮助我的事情，但我无法停止。为什么我一直在喝酒？比如，为什么我睡前不读书？为什么我继续不做出我想做的举动？你一直经历的那种无聊实际上正在关闭你大脑做出创造性的、
new, fresh choices towards your life. Besides those two factors, I do think there's a third thing. And I do think that that is acknowledging that sometimes, yes, the world around us is boring, is difficult, is putting us in a funk. Sometimes it's not fun to admit, but sometimes we are the funk, though. We have become the bad day. We have become the bad mood. We become the one ruining things for ourselves and sometimes ruining things for others. And it can create quite a self-fulfilling prophecy that we do need to snap out of. Like there is a level of acknowledgement and accountability with certain funk states that maybe we are, we're kind of playing into it a little bit. Literally, this is a realization I've kind of had to sit within
新的、新鲜的选择来面对你的生活的能力。除了这两个因素，我确实认为有第三件事。我确实认为那是承认有时，是的，我们周围的世界是无聊的，是困难的，正在让我们陷入低谷。有时承认这一点并不有趣，但有时我们就是那个低谷。我们已经变成了糟糕的一天。我们已经变成了糟糕的心情。我们变成了那个为自己毁掉事情，有时也为他人毁掉事情的人。它可以创造一个我们确实需要摆脱的自我实现的预言。就像对于某些低谷状态，有一种承认和责任感，也许我们，我们有点在其中扮演角色。字面上，这是我不得不坐在其中实现的认识
recent months. Again, I went through this period when I first moved to London where every day was a bad day. And I realized that was probably because I was waking up expecting it to be a bad day. So I unconsciously, throughout every day I would wake up and I would be searching for evidence of this pre-existing expectation. And I was probably even creating situations that matched my expectations without realizing it. Like, when I was on the train, I started to realize that I would only notice the people who, like, didn't give up their seats for the elderly. I would only notice the people who bumped into me or the people who wouldn't move out of somebody's way. I never at the time noticed the people who were being kind, or the kid with like the new Barbie doll, or like the
最近几个月。同样，我刚搬到伦敦时经历过这段时期，每天都是糟糕的一天。我意识到那可能是因为我醒来时期待着那是糟糕的一天。所以我下意识地，在每一天里，我醒来时都会寻找这种预先存在的期望的证据。我甚至可能在没有意识到的情况下创造了符合我期望的情况。比如，当我在火车上时，我开始意识到我只会注意到那些没有给老人让座的人。我只会注意到那些撞到我的人或那些不从别人路上移开的人。当时我从未注意到那些善良的人，或者那个拿着新芭比娃娃的孩子，或者
couple in love. Both of those groups of people were present, but I was only noticing one half. It was this filter I was applying onto the world around me, when in fact, like, the world was rather neutral. There were some people who were being annoying, some people who were being fantastic, most people who were just existing. I could only see the annoying people. Psychologically to give this a name, this is called mood, congruent perception. Basically, our pre-existing feelings about something, go on to incorrectly dictate what we see, what we remember, what we experience in a way that does not match objective reality. This was actually first described by Gordon Bauer. He is like one of the most, you might not know this. He's one of the most famous cognitive psychologists. Fun fact,
相爱的情侣。这两组人都存在，但我只注意到了其中一半。这是我应用在我周围世界上的过滤器，而事实上，世界是相当中立的。有些人很烦人，有些人很棒，大多数人只是存在着。我只能看到那些烦人的人。在心理学上给这个命名，这被称为情绪一致性感知。基本上，我们对某事的预先存在的感受，会错误地支配我们看到什么、记住什么、体验什么，其方式与客观现实不符。这实际上是由 Gordon Bauer 首先描述的。他是，你可能不知道这一点。他是最著名的认知心理学家之一。有趣的事实，
Gordon Bauer is actually a creator of pneumonic devices. He's also responsible for like so much of what we know about memory and short-term and long-term memory and working memory. But he identified this specific phenomena, mood congruent perception in the 80s when he noticed that he could get people to remember different aspects of a situation, not by changing the situation, but by changing how they felt. So he would deliberately, you know, make them angry, make them sad, make them frustrated, and then be like, what did you notice about the situation? that whatever mental and mood-like state he put them in would actually almost systematically change what they saw. We have to be aware of this attention or bias. It's tricky when
Gordon Bauer 实际上是助记设备的创造者。他还负责我们所知道的关于记忆、短期和长期记忆以及工作记忆的很多知识。但他确定了这种特定的现象，情绪一致性感知，在 80 年代，当他注意到他可以通过改变人们的感受，而不是改变情况，来让他们记住情况的不同方面。所以他会故意，你知道，让他们生气，让他们悲伤，让他们沮丧，然后问，你注意到了关于这种情况的什么？他让他们进入的任何心理和情绪状态实际上几乎系统地改变了他们所看到的东西。我们必须意识到这种注意或偏见。当你
you're already in it, but genuinely call yourself out when you are being the bad mood. Call yourself out when you have bad expectations at the start of every day that this day's going to turn out just like the others. It's going to be shit. genuinely, I think that really stuffed me out of it was realizing that the distance between being annoyed and amused is quite small. And if you can just shift across those mood states, the load becomes lighter. Like if I was really annoyed at something, I'd be like, but also this is kind of funny, right? Shift from annoyed to amuse because they sit very close together on like the emotional scale. Let's talk about some of the worst things that you can do when you are in a funk.
已经身处其中时，这很棘手，但当你处于糟糕的心情时，真正地指出自己。当你每天开始时有糟糕的期望，认为这一天会像其他日子一样时，指出自己。这会很糟糕。真的，我认为真正让我摆脱它的是意识到从烦恼到被逗乐之间的距离很小。如果你能只是跨越那些情绪状态，负荷就会变轻。比如，如果我对某事真的很烦，我会说，但这也很有趣，对吧？从烦恼转变为被逗乐，因为它们在情绪量表上坐得非常近。让我们谈谈当你陷入低谷时你能做的最糟糕的一些事情。
We're going to take a short break. When we return, we're going to jump into it. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists. Like back in the day pride.
我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将跳进去。骄傲就像爱。你能在心里感受到它。IR. Radio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括 IHart Pride Canada，你最喜欢的热门歌曲和必备的派对歌曲，加上个性化和策划的播放列表。就像过去的日子里的骄傲。
Celebrate love. Take pride with you. Anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified.
庆祝爱。随身携带骄傲。随时随地。只需让您的智能扬声器播放 IHart Pride Canada。在您的手机上流式传输我们或立即在 iHeartRadio.ca 收听。在那一刻，感觉它好像永远在持续。我以为我活不下去了。我吓坏了。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child.
那些眼睛里空洞无物。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案？是的，先生。敢说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？是的，先生。强奸谋杀一个孩子。
Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app.
就像最糟糕的情况一样。我想是的。Evil，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹 Crevette 和 DePippo 谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo 在被判处最高刑罚后，没有表现出任何悔意，显得泰然自若。我说我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。请在 Iheart radio 应用程序上收听 The Devil's Quarry。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear The Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult.
Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。要收听无广告且包含独家内容的 The Devil's Quarry，请在 Apple Podcasts 上订阅 Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是 Hoda Kotby，播客 Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby 的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如当女演员 Olivia Munn 分享她如何克服严重的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier Tichorito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions. ever since I was born and I still have so many questions
有很多了解产后抑郁症的人。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby。因为他们的新星是 Javier Tichorito Hernandez。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系、情绪。我仍然有很多问题
where do we come from what happens after death how do you deal with cancellation Cristiano or Messi do aliens exist what is love Real Madrid or Barza from everyday
我们从哪里来，死后会发生什么，你如何处理取消，克里斯蒂亚诺还是梅西，外星人存在吗，什么是爱，皇家马德里还是巴萨，从日常
and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary this isn't a normal podcast everything here is spontaneous real and genuine this podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends where vulnerability
和普通到深刻和非凡，这不是一个普通的播客，这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈，在那里脆弱
conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are all in this life has an order perfect and everything is just. Wait me, I'm going to be going to be
阴谋论被摆上桌面，目标和教训都在这个生活中有一个完美的顺序，一切都只是。等等我，我将要，我将要
going to be able to connect. We are here to connect The Chicharito. I'm Javier El Chicharino and together with IHA Radio we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary.
能够连接。我们在这里连接 The Chicharito。我是 Javier El Chicharino，与 IHA Radio 一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。
Stay close. It's a crack. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Keith Gianmanca
靠近点。这是一个裂缝。哇。请在 IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Learning to Be Human。Keith Gianmanca
seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly he became someone else. A master of disguise, who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy. But I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out.
看起来像一个温和的郊区父亲，但私下里他变成了另一个人。一个伪装大师，他进行了一场犯罪狂欢。当时，这看起来是个疯狂的想法吗？这看起来非常疯狂。但我感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。
Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong and what that might look like? No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover, that your dad has been living a double life. That is not the look of an innocent man.
你允许自己思考它会如何出错以及那可能是什么样子吗？不，我不想显现那个。我试图显现成功。每个家庭都有它的秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时会发生什么。那不是一个无辜男人的样子。
This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So there are some things that are going to make your funk worse. scientifically. The first is when you chase or soothe with quick dopamine constantly, or when you involve yourself in passive consumption rather than turning your attention towards long-term gratification. You'll know it, but when you're in a funk, your phone scrolling may feel
这将永远改变我的生活和我的家庭动态，因为之前存在于我现实中的一切现在都不真实了。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Deep Cover the Family Man。所以有些事情会使你的低谷变得更糟。在科学上。第一是当你不断地追求或用快速的多巴胺来抚慰，或者当你参与被动消费而不是将你的注意力转向长期满足时。你会知道的，当你陷入低谷时，你的手机滚动可能感觉
temporarily soothing, but it's actually just emotional avoidance. And at times, like it really is just like an unsustainable form of emotional regulation because it's just covering up the bad feelings without interrogating them and not doing anything to really investigate the root cause of why you feel so terrible. Like this is not going to pull you out of a funk. Consuming more is not going to help you. It may distract you from your thoughts for a little while, which, you know, sometimes is necessary. It may give you a little burst of dopamine. But you need to shift away from consumption to creation if you actually want something to change. Literally nothing changes if nothing changes. doom scrolling or distraction feels like something's changing because the hard feelings are being
暂时抚慰，但实际上这只是情绪回避。有时，它确实只是一种不可持续的情绪调节形式，因为它只是掩盖了糟糕的感觉而没有审视它们，也没有做任何事情来真正调查你感觉如此糟糕的根本原因。这不会把你从低谷中拉出来。消费更多不会帮助你。它可能会让你暂时从思绪中分心，这，你知道，有时是必要的。它可能会给你一点多巴胺的爆发。但如果你真的想改变什么，你需要从消费转向创造。字面上，如果什么都不改变，什么都不会改变。无聊滚动或分心感觉好像有什么在改变，因为困难的感觉正在被
quieted for a while like they're kind of going away nothing it's just turning down the volume we've you know we have to get into this creation mindset which we're going to talk about in a second but there's some other things that you can that you are probably doing that aren't good for you for you being in this funk the second one is self-isolating it feels like the easiest thing in the world, right? To do much girl, but also to self-isolate, especially since, let's be honest, when we're in a funk, people are just really annoying. Even the people you love most, you just don't want them in your space. Because your entire nervous system is already being, like, repeatedly graded by life like a freaking cheese grater. But you need to fight that urge to push people
安静了一会儿，好像它们正在消失，什么都没有，它只是调低了音量，我们，你知道，我们必须进入这种创造心态，我们一会儿会谈到，但还有一些其他事情你可能正在做，这对你陷入这个低谷并不好。第二个是自我隔离，这感觉像是世界上最简单的事情，对吧？去做很多女孩，但也去自我隔离，特别是既然，让我们诚实地说，当我们陷入低谷时，人们真的很烦人。即使是你最爱的人，你也不想让他们进入你的空间。因为你的整个神经系统已经被生活像一个该死的奶酪刨丝器一样反复摩擦。但你需要对抗那种把人推开的冲动
aside and to withdraw from them and realize this is what, this is, this is, this is, you have to realize it for what it is, which is your brain is trying to avoid stimulation, friction, and oversaturation of any kind. The problem is this instinct becomes self-reinforcing. Social withdrawal reduces opportunities for positive reinforcement, like connection, like laughter, like support, and that in itself would provide proof that life is better than you think it is. But when we are withdrawing, we're essentially shutting down opportunities for life to give us evidence, for its own goodness. I do think it's important to acknowledge that sometimes we don't want to see others and we don't want to be around others because of feelings of shame that arise from being in a funk.
并从他们身边撤退，并意识到这是什么，这是，这是，你必须意识到它的本质，即你的大脑试图避免任何形式的刺激、摩擦和过度饱和。问题是这种本能变得自我强化。社交退缩减少了积极强化的机会，比如联系、笑声、支持，而这本身就会提供证据证明生活比你想象的要好。但当我们退缩时，我们本质上是在关闭生活给我们提供证据的机会，为了它自己的善良。我确实认为承认有时我们不想见别人，也不想和别人在一起，因为陷入低谷而产生的羞耻感是很重要的。
Definitely in today's hyperproductive society, always working, always hustling, always making big moves, always happy. You know, sometimes we don't want to be the buzzkill. You don't want to be the one who's like throwing that off. But it's unrealistic to think that we will always be like that. And something I've been saying to myself more and more is that giving people the opportunity to love you through ugly seasons of life is a gift to them as much as it is a gift to you. Seriously, ask yourself, I'll think about it as well, but I kind of already know my answer because I already know the question I'm going to ask, but do you get a sense of fulfillment and satisfaction from helping your friends? Like, isn't it a great feeling when somebody wants your advice or asks you for help?
绝对在当今过度生产的社会中，总是工作，总是忙碌，总是做出重大举措，总是快乐。你知道，有时我们不想成为扫兴的人。你不想成为那个抛出那个的人。但认为我们总是那样是不现实的。我一直在对自己说的一件事是，给人们机会在生活的丑陋季节里爱你，这对他们来说是一份礼物，就像它对你来说是一份礼物一样。认真地，问问自己，我也会考虑它，但我已经知道我要问的问题的答案了，但你从帮助你的朋友中获得成就感和满足感吗？比如，当有人想要你的建议或向你寻求帮助时，这不是一种很棒的感觉吗？
because it's like, it's this beautiful thing of like, oh my God, you thought of me. You wanted me during this time. Like, I'll be right over it. That's a great feeling to feel wanted, even if it's to help somebody. If you feel that joy in helping others, don't deprive them from getting to have that same feeling as well with you. Also, just from a purely scientific perspective, study after study will tell you that even if self-isolating feels good temporarily, your brain just does cope better with people around
因为这就像，这是一种美丽的事情，比如，天哪，你想到我了。你在这段时间想要我。比如，我马上就到。那种被需要的感觉很棒，即使是为了帮助别人。如果你在帮助他人中感受到那种快乐，不要剥夺他们也从你那里获得同样感觉的机会。此外，仅仅从纯粹的科学角度来看，一项又一项的研究会告诉你，即使自我隔离暂时感觉很好，你的大脑确实在有人的情况下处理得更好
to you. Even the deepest of introverts still needs to be seen sometimes. And we're not just talking physically here. We're talking emotionally. We thrive best in the safety of others. So those are two things that I definitely don't think you should be doing and you should be conscious of. Let's talk about the positive things that you can be adding back into your life. All the strategies, I should say, not all of these are about adding things. Some of the strategies that could maybe help you get out of a funk. what actually works in these situations is a couple of things. I think my very simple advice of like get off your phone and see your friends only takes us so far. But you really need to be conscious of, again, the factors in your life that are making it harder for you to feel optimistic about life.
在你身边。即使是最深沉的内向者有时也需要被看到。我们在这里谈论的不仅仅是身体上的。我们谈论的是情感上的。我们在他人的安全中茁壮成长。所以这是两件我绝对认为你不应该做的事情，你应该意识到。让我们谈谈你可以重新添加到你生活中的积极事情。所有的策略，我应该说，并非所有这些都是关于添加东西。一些可能有助于你摆脱低谷的策略。在这些情况下真正有效的是几件事。我认为我关于放下手机和见朋友的非常简单的建议只能带我们走这么远。但你真的需要意识到，再次，你生活中那些让你更难对生活感到乐观的因素。
And I know I said some things that you could add. Let's start with the things that you need to subtract. Before you try and add more things into your routine, more novelty, more creation, it's very easy to just add more things in, but at some point, you are going to have to sit down with a piece of paper, sit down and look at your life and just have an honesty moment and list everything that is making your life suck. Sometimes you need to do a bit of an audit. Every habit, every weekly activity, every obligation, I want you to write it down. What do you think the reason your life sucks right now? Where is it coming from? This could be seeing friends that you've outgrown. It could be drinking alcohol. It could be a really long and inefficient commute. It could be
我知道我说了一些你可以添加的事情。让我们从你需要减去的事情开始。在你尝试在你的日常生活中添加更多东西、更多新鲜感、更多创造力之前，添加更多东西很容易，但在某个时候，你将不得不坐下来拿一张纸，坐下来看看你的生活，进行一次诚实的时刻，列出所有让你生活变得糟糕的事情。有时你需要进行一点审计。每一个习惯、每一个每周活动、每一个义务，我希望你写下来。你认为你现在生活变得糟糕的原因是什么？它来自哪里？这可能是见你已经超越的朋友。这可能是喝酒。这可能是非常漫长且低效的通勤。这可能是
where you live. It could be reading the comments on reels. It could be looking at your phone first thing in the morning. It could be always doing everything from eating to showering to exercising in a very rushed, frantic manner. I need you to really do an audit. Think about whether the things that are genuinely making your life worse are essentials or they could be changed. And think about as well, why you are doing them? Why are you drinking?
你住的地方。这可能是阅读评论。这可能是早上第一件事就是看手机。这可能是总是以一种非常匆忙、疯狂的方式做所有事情，从吃饭到洗澡到锻炼。我需要你真正进行一次审计。想想那些真正让你的生活变得更糟的事情是必需品，还是它们可以改变。还要想想，为什么你在做它们？你为什么要喝酒？
Why are you still seeing these people? Why are you still living in the city? Do you need these things in your life if they make life harder? sometimes being in a funk is made worse by looking at all the things you have to go through in the next few weeks and months ahead, looking at all the things in your to-do list, and wanting to do none of them, and just feeling a deep sense of like there is nothing to look forward to, because my circumstances are crap. This has a name. It's called anticipatory dread. Basically, our brain scans the future, thinks about all the horrible things waiting for us that could or couldn't happen.
你为什么还在见这些人？你为什么还住在这个城市？如果这些事情让生活变得更难，你需要它们在你的生活中吗？有时陷入低谷是因为看着你在未来几周和几个月内必须经历的所有事情，看着你待办事项清单上的所有事情，并且不想做其中任何一件，只是感到一种深深的，比如没有什么值得期待的，因为我的情况很糟糕。这有一个名字。它被称为预期恐惧。基本上，我们的大脑扫描未来，思考等待我们的所有可怕的事情，这些事情可能发生也可能不发生。
and that makes us feel terrible because it borrows all the future frustration, anger, annoyance, and it makes it your current problem. Again, have a genuine sit down, have an intervention with yourself tonight. What are the pain points in your life? What are the things you keep bumping up against and keep going out and haven't thought to remove? Once you do that, then you can get down to kind of adding things in. And the first thing I think everyone should be prescribed more of is time in nature. People are increasingly turning to nature-based interventions to deal with like the
这让我们感觉很糟糕，因为它借用了所有的未来挫折、愤怒、烦恼，并使它成为你当前的问题。再次，进行一次真正的坐下来，今晚对自己进行一次干预。你生活中的痛点是什么？你不断撞到并不断走出去，却没有想到要移除的事情是什么？一旦你这样做了，你就可以开始添加东西了。我认为每个人都应该被开出更多处方的第一件事是与大自然相处。人们越来越多地转向基于自然的干预措施来处理，比如
cognitive overload of modern life because it resets something really fundamental in us, mainly our natural human drives. Being in nature resets our curiosity, resets our attentional systems, resets our sense of awe. in fact there is this fascinating idea I personally love called the biophilia hypothesis which basically says that every human all of us we are innately driven to seek out a connection with nature and to return to nature and when that is prevented we suffer when we haven't had enough time in the woods by the ocean in the trees in the bush there's a part of us that switches off. A meta-analysis from 2022 actually looked at 39 studies that examined the link
现代生活的认知过载，因为它重置了我们内心非常根本的东西，主要是我们人类的天性。置身于大自然中能重置我们的好奇心、注意力系统和敬畏感。事实上，有一个我个人非常喜欢的迷人概念，叫做“亲生命假说”，它基本上认为每个人，我们所有人，天生就被驱动去寻求与自然的联系，并回归自然。当这种联系受阻时，我们就会受苦。当我们没有足够的时间待在森林里、海边、树林中或灌木丛中时，我们内心的一部分就会关闭。2022年的一项荟萃分析实际上研究了39项探讨这一联系的研究，
between spending time in nature and mental health conditions. 92% of these studies demonstrated consistent improvements across any and every health outcome when individuals engaged with natural outdoor environments. Mental health outcomes specifically improved in 98% of these studies. So not in 98% of people, 98% of these studies. Physical and cognitive health outcomes as well showed improvements around 83 and 75%. Respectively, that is a huge success rate. If those studies were investigating a cure for a deadly disease, an 83, 75, 98% improvement, like, that would represent a seismic result. It would be making headlines. Nature resets out. Nature resets out. brain like nothing else. So if you are in a funk and you have the time or you can make the time,
即在大自然中度过的时间与心理健康状况之间的联系。92%的研究表明，当个人接触自然户外环境时，各种健康结果都有一致的改善。具体来说，98%的研究中心理健康结果得到了改善。所以不是98%的人，而是98%的研究。身体和认知健康结果也分别显示出约83%和75%的改善。这是一个巨大的成功率。如果这些研究是在调查一种致命疾病的治疗方法，83%、75%、98%的改善率，那将是一个惊人的结果。它会成为头条新闻。大自然能像其他任何事物一样重置我们的大脑。所以，如果你感到情绪低落，并且有时间或者可以挤出时间，
dedicate yourself to an outdoor day or an outdoor afternoon or an outdoor three or to four hours once a week. And even if it requires a little bit of travel, if you live in a big city, I really do think it's worth it. It's fundamental. Whilst you are outside, I have another strategy that you can combine with your prescribed nature time. This is a combo. And then, this is an exercise I started doing a little while ago to kind of overcome against some of that projected negativity. I was having specifically towards others, which I'm not proud of, but it was happening. What I did to counteract that sense of like, everybody's annoying, everybody's in my way, everybody's blah, blah, blah, was that as I was walking, running, riding, whatever it was,
让自己每周花一个下午或三到四个小时去户外。即使这需要一点路程，如果你住在在大城市，我真的认为这是值得的。这是根本性的。当你外出时，我还有另一个策略可以与你预定的自然时间结合使用。这是一个组合。这是我前段时间开始做的一项练习，旨在克服我对他人的那种投射性负面情绪，我对此并不感到自豪，但它确实发生了。为了抵消那种“每个人都很烦人，每个人都挡我的路，每个人都……”的感觉，我所做的是，当我走路、跑步、骑车或做任何事情时，
as people passed me by, I made myself focus in on one person at a time, one after another, and every single person I had to give them a compliment in my mind. So if I was sitting on the tube, and there was five people in front of me, I would silently have to go one, two, three, four, five and give them all a compliment. I must have talked about this for, but like it's a habit that truly shifted me out of a really dark, pessimistic time.
当人们从我身边经过时，我强迫自己一次只关注一个人，一个接一个，而且我必须在心里给每个人一个赞美。所以如果我坐在地铁上，前面有五个人，我会默默地数一、二、三、四、五，并给他们每个人一个赞美。我一定谈论过这个，但这确实是一个让我从一段非常黑暗、悲观的时期中走出来的习惯。
It forced my brain to have to see the good in everyone and everything when it was looking for the worst. Even the most like unassuming person, you can find something cooler interesting about them. Like, you can be like, wow, her hair color, his choice of tie. I can tell he's really enjoying his music. Oh, what a beautiful relationship he has with his daughter. It becomes this really nice ritual of looking for the good. A 2017 paper also found habits like this, rituals like this, orient you towards the good side of humanity. And they actually
它强迫我的大脑在寻找最坏情况时，必须看到每个人和每件事好的一面。即使是最不起眼的人，你也能发现他们身上酷或有趣的地方。比如，你可以想：“哇，她的发色真好看”，“他选的领带真不错”，“我看得出他真的很享受他的音乐”，“哦，他和女儿的关系真好”。这变成了一种寻找美好的非常好的仪式。2017年的一篇论文也发现，这样的习惯、这样的仪式，会引导你走向人性美好的一面。而且它们实际上
do in fact make people nicer to you, which in turn changes your expectations about how nice people actually are becoming a self-fulfilling prophecy in the opposite direction. Another thing we need to make sure we're doing is fulfilling our core soul needs. I love this concept. I talked about it in our episode, quite a similar episode actually now that I think about it, on how to rediscover your personality. It's like from early, like January this year. You know, now that I think about it probably is like an amazing companion episode to this one.
确实会让人们对你更友善，这反过来又改变了你对人们实际上有多友善的期望，从而成为一种反向的自我实现的预言。我们需要确保做的另一件事是满足我们核心的灵魂需求。我喜欢这个概念。我在我们关于如何重塑个性的那一集中谈到过它，现在想起来，那一集和这一集非常相似。那是今年一月左右的事。你知道，现在想起来，这可能是这一集的一个绝佳配套节目。
but in that episode I talk about soul needs. Soul needs are the spiritual things you do to fill your cup. And when I say spiritual, I don't mean religious, although that can definitely be a big part of it. I mean the stuff that makes you feel human, feel individual, feel like you are connected to others, and you are connected to the world that isn't always fulfilled by other things. And guess what? your soul needs aren't productive the way your other needs are. In fact, they don't need to achieve anything. They actually become more worthwhile if they're not achieving anything. And they
但在那一集中，我谈到了灵魂需求。灵魂需求是你为了充实内心而做的精神层面的事情。当我提到“精神”时，我指的不是宗教，尽管那肯定可以是其中的重要部分。我指的是那些让你感到自己是人、感到自己是独立的个体、感到自己与他人相连、并与世界相连的事情，而这些往往无法通过其他事物来满足。你猜怎么着？你的灵魂需求不像你的其他需求那样具有生产力。事实上，它们不需要实现任何目标。如果它们不实现任何目标，它们反而变得更有价值。而且它们
include things that inspire adventure, that inspire curiosity. They include needs like playfulness, silliness, humor, kinship, indulgence, or savoring things. Soul needs. Filling your soul needs, you know, might include listening to your favorite album. It might include having great sex. It might include, well, having great sex with yourself or somebody else. It might include really laboring over a meal, really like getting fresh, tasty ingredients, making that meal is an act of love to yourself, having a bath, laying in the grass, anything that reminds you that you are not a machine, which is hard to come by in this day and age.
包括激发冒险精神、激发好奇心的事物。它们包括像顽皮、傻气、幽默、亲情、放纵或细细品味事物等需求。灵魂需求。满足你的灵魂需求，可能包括听你最喜欢的专辑。可能包括享受美妙的性生活。可能包括，嗯，与自己或他人享受美妙的性生活。可能包括精心准备一顿饭，像获取新鲜、美味的食材，制作那顿饭是对自己的一种爱，泡个澡，躺在草地上，任何提醒你不是机器的事情，这在当今时代很难得。
Protect your soul needs. view them as just as important as your physical needs and try and fulfill just one soul need per day outside of your normal habits as a person. Make it a priority. Again, almost prescribe this to yourself like an intervention, like a medication. Sprinkle them back into your life, like a soul need supplement, like your freaking tinkerbell. Remember, when we are in a funk, it's often an aggregation of just like little things that have let us down or got us down. But it's also an aggregation of the loss of the little things that lift us up as well. Like I genuinely think it's like two sides of the same coin. So make sure that that is an active priority for you. Of course, on top of
保护你的灵魂需求。把它们看得和你的生理需求一样重要，并尝试每天在你的正常习惯之外满足至少一个灵魂需求。把它作为优先事项。再说一次，几乎像干预措施或药物一样给自己开这个处方。把它们重新撒回你的生活中，就像灵魂需求的补充剂，就像你那该死的奇妙仙子。记住，当我们情绪低落时，通常是那些让我们失望或让我们沮丧的小事的累积。但它也是那些能让我们振作起来的小事缺失的累积。我真心认为这是同一枚硬币的两面。所以确保这成为你的一个积极优先事项。当然，在此基础上，
that and following on from before, try and also commit to doing new things, practicing small deviations from the routine. If novelty and a lack of it is why we end up in a funk, it obviously makes sense logically that adding it back in might reverse the funk. But like, it doesn't have to be monumental, just like taking a different route on your way home from work, going to the supermarket and only buying from brands you've never tried, or only getting stuff you've always been like, oh my God, I always wanted to try that. Like that kind of novelty, reshuffling the layout of your house, listening to a new album every single day instead of the same stuff. Checking out a film, you probably wouldn't normally watch, maybe something with subtitles.
并延续之前的内容，尝试承诺做一些新事情，练习对常规进行小小的偏离。如果新鲜感及其缺乏是我们陷入低谷的原因，那么逻辑上讲，重新加入新鲜感可能会扭转这种低谷。但这不必是重大的，比如下班回家走不同的路线，去超市只买你从未尝试过的品牌，或者只买那些你一直想说“天哪，我一直想试试那个”的东西。那种新鲜感，重新布置你的房子，每天听一张新专辑而不是听同样的东西。看一部你平时可能不会看的电影，也许是带字幕的。
Like, all these things, meeting your friends at different places rather than just the same old pub, like switching up your gym routine. These things are so small and they are not life-changing, but they fundamentally change your brain and your perception of reality because they just make you see that a different reality is possible, even if it is only a degree of separation away from your previous reality. If you want to commit to something more major, If your funk is really getting to an intense level, perhaps you could request like a few days off work and use those days to do something brand new for yourself. My friend, she did a, my friend Shelby, amazing woman, did a surfing course last year because she's the coolest person alive. And she was like that was a reset for me.
比如，所有这些事情，在不同的地方见朋友而不是总是去同一个老酒吧，比如改变你的健身习惯。这些事情非常小，它们不会改变生活，但它们从根本上改变了你的大脑和对现实的感知，因为它们让你看到不同的现实是可能的，即使它离你之前的现实只有一度之差。如果你想致力于更重大的事情，如果你的低谷真的达到了强烈的程度，也许你可以请几天假，利用这些天为你自己做一些全新的事情。我的朋友，她做了一个，我的朋友谢尔比，了不起的女性，去年参加了一个冲浪课程，因为她是世界上最酷的人。她说那对我来说是一个重置。
Just creating new distinct memories you never thought you were going to create, especially in your 20s. Firstly, medicine to cure the funk. also psychologically protective long term, so that when you perhaps are in the state again, you can come back to this time when you really pushed yourself out of this moment and feel confident that you will survive again. Again, novel experiences are so valuable. They trigger slow dopamine release. They improve neuroplasticity. They give us a sense that there is more to live for. and so especially if like you've just started a nine to five job especially if you've just moved into a corporate career especially if like you're finding work and life and relationships overwhelming
创造你从未想过会创造的新的独特记忆，尤其是在你20多岁的时候。首先，这是治愈低谷的良药。从长远来看，它在心理上也是一种保护，这样当你再次处于这种状态时，你可以回到这段你真正把自己从这种时刻推出来的时光，并确信你会再次挺过来。再说一次，新奇的体验非常有价值。它们会触发缓慢的多巴胺释放。它们改善神经可塑性。它们让我们感觉到生活还有更多值得期待的东西。所以，特别是如果你刚开始朝九晚五的工作，特别是如果你刚进入企业职业生涯，特别是如果你觉得工作、生活和人际关系让你不知所措，
this needs i literally cannot stress enough how mentally vital this is for you i think being stuck in a fun because obviously something that can feel never-ending i've been there i'm in it with you at times i probably was a couple months ago very deep in it but i promise you it will end feeling flat and unmotivated. Terrible ways to feel, but they aren't permanent. You guys know how I feel about the winters of life, but I truly believe that some years and months are filled with activity, filled with harvest, filled with new opportunities, filled with feelings of optimism. That cannot be the season all the time. You need the seasons where things are slow and dull and not necessarily what you want them to be to support the summers of life. It's just,
这些需求，我真的无法强调这对你的心理有多重要。我认为陷入低谷，因为这显然是一种感觉永无止境的事情，我经历过，有时我和你在一起，我可能几个月前就深陷其中，但我向你保证它会结束。感到平淡和缺乏动力。感觉很糟糕，但它们不是永久的。你们知道我对人生之冬的看法，但我真心相信，有些年份和月份充满了活动，充满了收获，充满了新的机会，充满了乐观的感觉。那不可能一直都是那个季节。你需要那些事情缓慢、沉闷且不一定是你想要的样子来支持人生之夏。这只是，
just natural as much as like winter, autumn, spring, summer are natural parts of how nature regenerates itself and cycles through itself and has different periods for different seasons and different feelings. Like you have that as well. And not to put like a toxic, positive spin on it, but sometimes when I am in a funk and, you know, the one I was in previously, I was like, what is this trying to tell me about how I can deepen my experience of being alive? And like, what is this current state trying to tell me about what I need to reprioritize in my life and the rest that I need and the habits that need to change. And so I think even though it's terrible, it is still a valuable experience, obviously do all these things and obviously we want to rush out of these moments
就像冬天、秋天、春天、夏天是大自然如何自我再生、循环往复并为不同季节和不同感受拥有不同时期一样自然。你也有这样的时期。并不是要给它加上一种有毒的积极色彩，但有时当我处于低谷时，你知道，我之前经历的那次，我会想，这试图告诉我关于我如何加深作为活着的体验？当前的这种状态试图告诉我关于我生活中需要重新优先考虑什么，我需要的休息，以及需要改变的习惯。所以我认为尽管它很糟糕，但它仍然是一种有价值的体验，显然要做所有这些事情，显然我们想尽快冲出这些时刻，
as fast as possible and we want to like feel better as fast as possible. But it's also important to just use this as a cue for what isn't going right and what temporary fixes maybe aren't working and do a full reset. Do a full seasonal winter reset so that you can kind of come alive in this next season of life, having kind of plowed and replanted, oh my God, I'm really taking this metaphor for a run, but like having really, yeah, replanted your garden with more fertile, more blossoming habits, practices and routines that match you better. So that is all we have time for today. I really hope that this episode, I hope it gets you out of a funk. I hope it gets you out of a funk. I hope it gets you're thinking about maybe what needs to change in your life and not feeling ashamed that maybe
并想尽快感觉好起来。但同样重要的是，要利用这个作为什么地方出了问题以及哪些临时修复措施可能不起作用的线索，并进行全面重置。进行一次全面的季节性冬季重置，这样你就可以在人生的下一个季节里焕发活力，因为你已经耕耘并重新种植了——天哪，我真的把这个比喻用得太过了——但就像真的重新种植了你的花园，用更肥沃、更繁茂的习惯、实践和更适合你的常规。所以这就是我们今天所有的时间。我真的希望这一集，我希望它能让你走出低谷。我希望它能让你走出低谷。我希望它能让你思考生活中可能需要改变什么，而不是因为
something in your life isn't going right and it is like you do have the opportunity to fix it. Like I think just taking accountability for the fact that your life isn't perfect is not a shameful thing. It's like the best part of new beginnings is like the beginning is the beginning stages and is this moment of recognition. So I hope you're able to take some motivation and inspiration from this and like change something in your life, whether it is dramatic or. not. Thank you as always to our researcher Lucy Davidson for doing a lot of the research and looking into a lot of the papers for today's episode. I feel like they were so cool and fascinating
生活中有些事情进展不顺利而感到羞耻，你确实有机会修复它。我认为仅仅为你的生活不完美这一事实承担责任并不是一件可耻的事情。就像新开始最棒的部分是开始阶段，这是认知的时刻。所以我希望你能从中获得一些动力和灵感，改变你生活中的某些东西，无论是戏剧性的还是不那么戏剧性的。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森为今天的节目做了大量的研究并查阅了许多论文。我觉得它们非常酷且引人入胜，
to read through. You can follow us on social substack. You can buy a book. You can look at our website. I don't know if anybody looks at websites anymore, but the option is there in the links below. We also always include some of our favorite sources. So if you want to go deeper into this episode and some of the research we spoke about, you can do so below. If you haven't yet, watch an episode on Netflix, just for me, just so you can check it out and see what it looks like. I do think our set is really, really cool. So we'd love to see you over there, but until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. I hope you get out of your funk. Soon, we will talk later.
读起来很有意思。你可以在社交媒体、Substack上关注我们。你可以买书。你可以查看我们的网站。我不知道还有没有人看网站，但下面的链接里有这个选项。我们还总是包含一些我们最喜欢的来源。所以如果你想深入了解这一集和我们谈到的一些研究，你可以在下面这样做。如果你还没有，在Netflix上观看一集，就为了我，去看看它是什么样子的。我确实认为我们的布景非常非常酷。所以我们很乐意在那里见到你，但下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。希望你早日走出低谷。我们稍后再聊。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave.
那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波谋杀案发生的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后没有表现出任何悔意，看起来泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会把它带进坟墓。
Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential. And it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Bone Valley Feed中的“魔鬼采石场”。快乐是必不可少的。它也是难以捉摸的。但现在，有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开始你的旅程，迈向更快乐的生活，Joy 101。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。
If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player But before anything else, I'm human Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems
如果你渴望灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由霍达·科特比主持的Joy 101由CVS呈现。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天我仍在学习如何处理问题，
mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHare Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast.
错误、人际关系、情绪，从我出生起就是这样。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的和真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·托纳内兹，在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。
Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life. That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
每个家庭都有自己的秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时会发生什么？那不是一个无辜者的样子。每个人都在对我撒谎吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我必须做的事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深层掩护：居家男人》。
you get your podcasts. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created this show why I was unhoused on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares unhoused stories and news from the unhoused perspective. Listen to Weythian House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast.
多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个单一的群体。《无家可归者》是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创建了这个节目。我们已经成长为一个两届威比奖获奖播客，是唯一一个从无家可归者视角分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《无家可归者》。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证人性。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。